now nearly three weeks into this war of
choice by vladimir putin we see the
horrors of his brutality even against
civilians
we also know that with america run by a
hologram president with a hobbled
economy chaos reigns and our enemies are
emboldened the world is changing rapidly
and what happens next it's not easy to
predict
still there are signs that a peace deal
may be within reach
look at what's being discussed because
at the moment
the russians seem ready
to
accept ukraine as as neutral not in nato
but on the model of sweden or austria
potentially in the european union uh and
letting outside powers that would
certainly i think include the united
states provide guarantees of of
ukraine's uh security so if you listen
to what they're actually talking about
with their ukrainian counterparts and
ignore some of the more
steamy rhetoric the russian position is
shifting
and zelinski is shifting as well by
being realistic on nato membership
we have heard for many years about the
open doors but we also heard that we
can't enter those doors and this is
truth and we have simply to accept it as
it is
now there's clearly a deal here for the
making
yet do any of you feel watching tv or
reading online any urgency for peace
actual
peace
now of course putin could just decide to
stop the shelling right now but he's not
going to do that unless he gets
something for it
and president xi and one called vladimir
putin could end these hostilities
hey vlad no more wheat purchases no more
oil buys tavares until you stop the
killing
but she's not going to do that
now right now he has western europe and
america all tied up in knots
blowing billions of dollars trying to
help ukraine after the fact
then leaving more discounted russian oil
for china
and who else is acting as an impediment
to peace while we're at this
conversation
well people who don't seem particularly
bothered by the prospect of the war
dragging on well mostly for political
reasons that's what we're talking about
well the principal parties are clearly
trying to get to yes
we've already discovered that but the
biden administration
never seems to sound hopeful
we have not seen any concrete indication
from uh president putin that he is
serious about diplomacy that he is
serious about putting it into the
violence and
much to the contrary
and today biden didn't talk off-ramps or
a lot about peace but
it was all about punishment
and together with our allies and
partners
we will keep up the pressure on putin's
crumbling economy
isolating him on the global stage
that's our goal
make putin pay the price
well that's a nice applause line but as
we know sanctions rarely work
and then there's michael mcfaul the
former u.s ambassador to russia under
obama now he thinks zelinski not our own
elected officials should dictate our
ukraine policy
what about listening to him
rather than we pretend that we know what
he needs
what about if he thinks he needs these
weapons why don't we listen to him and
when we say oh they'll be shut down oh
he doesn't have airports to put those
migs in what about listening to his
judgment to help him fight the war that
he is he after all is the one fighting
the war
uh it's his country
so of course it's his job to fight for
it what is he talking about
plus is mcfall aware that congress
hasn't voted on an actual declaration of
war
or the fact that there's scant public
support for us to get into a shooting
war with russia does that matter at all
to him
now maybe mcfaul has bidenitis and
actually thinks zielinski
is our secretary of state or
our vice president
and let's not forget what senate
majority leader chuck schumer has said
when he urged peace
well he didn't urge peace that's a trick
question
he's too busy playing the fanboy role
in one sense his speech was reminiscent
of the stirring feeling all of us had in
the aftermath of 9 11
equal parts resolve and unity and
determination to save democracy
from an hour of darkness
now invoking 911 here is simply obscene
he sounds like he's repping zielinski
not his constituents
those words by the way don't calm things
down they ramp things up
do we want putin to really believe
that allah 911 were digging in for the
long deployment of u.s forces
and just as reckless is trump hating
soon-to-be former congressman adam
kinzinger
and i personally think we need to do a
no-fly zone i i think we've gotten to
the point though where there is
significant risk in inaction
now when zielinski calls for a no-fly
zone it's totally understandable i don't
blame them one bit
when kinziger does it it's highly
irresponsible
rather than doing what's in our national
interest which is avoiding a war with
russia he just stokes further tensions
oh and he didn't think i'd forget mitt
romney did you
enough talk
people are dying send them the planes
that they need they want migs get them
the migs
why don't you pay for them now
did he ever stop to think
that more people could die if we send
ukraine migs
and i'm not talking about russians
and last but not least
lindsey graham
do you still stand by your call to have
putin be assassinated
do you still stand by her yeah i hope
he'll be taken out
one way or the other i don't care how
they take him out i don't care if we
send him to the hague
and
uh try him i just want him to go yes if
john mccain were here and he'd be saying
the same thing
well we all want putin gone no doubt
about it and regarding john mccain god
rest his soul but mccain's also the guy
who saved obamacare wanted us mired in
syria and never wanted us out of
afghanistan graham's comments don't
ratchet down tension again they stoke
tension
the last thing we need is putin even
more paranoid than he already is
if he thinks he'll die or rot in prison
putin may just say forget negotiations
let it rip
so poopooing negotiations threatening
putin that's the easy stuff
and it's satisfying at the moment i get
it but it doesn't accomplish much
no one should be cynically thinking that
an extended conflict in ukraine is good
for him or her politically either i hope
they're not thinking that
because history shows that the longer a
war lasts the more costly it is by the
way to all involved
u.s policy makers have to be very
careful to make sure we do not end up in
a worse position when this is all over
and prolonging this by dismissing any
chance of peace or down playing it will
only ensure that more innocent people
are slaughtered
a lot of the same people who are
promising sure victory in ukraine if
zielinski just gets those migs or
surface-to-air missiles
where the same ones promising the same
in iraq and afghanistan
and we know how that all worked out for
us
we all know that both putin and
president xi are ruthless and determined
they must be resisted in a manner and in
a time that will be effective and
meaningful
reagan won the cold war by rebuilding
our economy and growing our military
which took a few years after the
devastation we faced under carter
the same pattern will have to play out
here
now as the angle is said from the
beginning the situation in ukraine
is a horrific tragedy it breaks all of
our hearts
but we have to be prudent and we have to
be thoughtful in our response
and right now the us is simply in no
good position to engage in another
protracted military struggle
we need time to repair our economy
reform our military and get political
leadership that actually works is good
is smart
whatever happens we cannot repeat the
same mistakes we made after 9 11.
and that's the angle